[Music]
and I'll for a little break from all
this activism we want to say hello to
our BFF besti Freedom Fighter Abu fatwa
in
gazaam alayum alayum and inshah Allah
will kill you all infidels thank you so
much for joining us love the headpiece
the all oppression Chic very D Mr
fatwa how are you are you safe oh yes
I'm safe I'm in a tunnel under the Gaza
Hospital
above me I have Allah and 2 million
civilians protecting me Community is so
important these
days all right people I'm Dave Ruben
this is the Ruben report it's November
6th in the year 2023 we're live
streaming as always on Rumble YouTube
and locals share subscribe tap that
notification Bell postgame show for you
over at Ruben report. locals . uh before
I address the cold open I'm very excited
because we have hired a new person
starting today Joey don't worry I'm only
going to say your first name but Joey is
a new addition to the Ruben report he
will be editing and doing other social
media related things and I mentioned
this not only to welcome Joey to the
team uh but also
because uh well he's a College Dropout
that's right I could have hired someone
from Harvard I could have hired a Hamas
sck from uh Stanford but instead I said
get me somebody with no formal education
for God's sakes we're doing work around
here so Joey uh welcome aboard that cold
open that we just showed you is from the
Israeli version of Saturday Night Live
and I wanted to show you just that small
portion there's a much bigger version of
it that's going on right now uh Catching
Fire across the internet uh but I
thought there was something really nice
about the ability to laugh amidst
tragedy right and as I I think it was
was it uh was it Billy wild said uh or
no it was Oscar wild who said comedy I
think was tragedy plus time was it Oscar
wild I think it was Oscar wild comedy is
tragedy plus time right and and the
story of the Jews is kind of that right
every Mel Brooks movie that you ever saw
making fun of uh Nazi Germany and the
Holocaust and everything else it's like
tragedy and then we better figure out a
way to laugh at this thing because
otherwise you could never go on with the
pain and I suppose in a time like this
when were're almost tomorrow I guess
will be one month to the day from these
horrific barbaric medieval uh attacks
that Hamas perpetrated upon these
Israelis um the time part of that is
starting to get shorter and shorter and
I think that that ironically is the
thing that they hate most about those
pesky Jews in Israel they figure out a
way to survive and laughing is part of
it right they've still got 200 hostages
there are 1500 people dead there are
Rockets being fired every day and yet
still they find a way to like fill those
spaces of life that need to be filled
when you're with goodness when you're
going through something uh horrible so I
wanted to uh show that up top uh and the
show today uh you know a lot of people
really enjoyed what we did on uh on
Friday which is something I consistently
try to do which is show you guys it's
not just about every day I could wake up
and be like these are the 20 horrible
things that happen and oh my God they're
happening right now but really give you
like a long look at how these things
happen how our institutions have failed
us again whether they're media as you
know or educational or corporate that
everything has been infected with this
woke ideology and it's leading to a
class of immoral people with radical
ideologies and a set of leaders who
don't know which way is up and whether
boys or girls and now a whole bunch of
people if you saw the videos over the
weekend all across Europe crazy protests
everywhere often violent uh and then
what happened right here in the United
States in the capital of America
Washington DC were thousands of Hamas
protesters and they are Hamas protesters
you do not have to think that they are
not you don't have to say that they are
not there is no one that shows up to
these things and says Hamas is bad guys
I'm for the people of Gaza but I'm
against Hamas right they would be
treated like the rest of us if they did
a bunch of Hamas protesters showed up to
the White House they were climbing the
fence they they desecrated the place
they were PT spray painting all over
jumping on uh on monuments and all all
sorts of other stuff and I suspect that
the elderly man pretending to be
president ain't going to do jack
about it oh I have a correction already
I like Corrections you guys know that it
was not Oscar wild who said that comedy
is tragedy plus time it was Steve Allen
wow Steve Allen former host of The
Tonight Show I think he was the second
ever was he the first host of The
Tonight Show or the second I'm really
pushing you right now I think he was the
first Steve Allen Tonight Show was he
the first host of the tonight's
show yes he was the first host of The
Tonight Show well Steve Allen you're no
longer with us but I want to give credit
where credit is due all right we're
going to get to all of that and more let
me talk to you guys about my Patriot
Supply real quick uh guys it's clear
that the unthinkable is here man this ad
just
fre with the recent media distractions
most folks never saw it coming but some
did their guts told them something was
wrong and the headlines are proving them
right our so-called trusted institutions
tell you not to worry that everything's
fine but you guys know better
self-reliance doesn't happen overnight
you have to start somewhere start with
my Patriot Supply my Patriot Supply the
country's largest preparedness company
is more than equipped to stock your
shelves ditch the canned vegetables and
box pasta their bestselling three-month
food kit provides delicious breakfast
and lunches and dinners that'll last up
to 25 years these meals offer 2,000
calories a day with a balance of protein
and carbs to keep you fed and ready in
case of an emergency just add water and
eat then eat start or strengthen your
food supply with this free month food
kit for my Patriot Supply visit prepare
withth ruben.com to get ready order now
for fast and free shipping prepare with
ruben.com okay so I want to start with a
clip of billmar and I know when I start
with these clips some of you go uh that
was an eye roll you go uh another one of
that liberal who doesn't get to the end
of the road but this one actually is not
really about trying to convince Mar of
anything this is Bill Mah getting
something right uh in the face of
someone who I would say is a woke
leftist who's gotten most of the things
wrong lately uh coid gender and a bunch
more Bill Maher had Neil degrass Tyson
and you guys know Neil degrass Tyson he
is I suppose a science Communicator once
what the great Carl Sean was Neil
degrass Tyson is kind of a cheap version
of that and he's really gone woke and to
Bill's credit although he still consid
himself a lefty and he said he wants
Gavin new some run for president which
could could we do we have a barf bag
here I'll I'll barf during the clip um
Bill does put up a fight against the
woke uh anyway here they got into it uh
Bill hitting Neil degrass Tyson or
plating to the woke instead of
challenging it and you will see how this
is connected to then getting a whole
bunch of intersectional zombies
attacking the White House in honor of
Hamas surely there's a portfolio jokes
that would still work on a college
campus surely I would hope not from what
may maybe some college campuses the ones
you read about are insane you've
given up on an entire
generation I given up on any place that
doesn't even remotely attempt to believe
in free speech and thinks that anything
that that they hear that they don't like
that they don't agree with is violence
these people are nuts and you
should be calling them out somebody like
you who has standing with kids should be
not
join you're doing what parents do you're
taking the path of least resistance and
therefore hurting the kids and yourself
parents ruined both their lives they
ruined their spoiled kids lives
and they ruined their own lives cuz the
kids rule the roost so that's what
you're doing on a national level I'm
feeling more like on the porch get off
my lawn I feel like we're in the barber
shop I want to give Bill Mah a lot of
credit here because uh you know that
show club random it's filmed at Bill's
house so Bill invites people like when I
do interviews in my house which I do
less of now uh but back in the day when
I was always inviting people to my house
there's there's a weird thing that
happens as an interviewer because you're
welcoming someone into your home so if
you disagree with them or if they say
something insane it's like well at the
most like extreme level they know where
you live and that could be problematic
but just at like a human respect level
to like be fighting with someone in your
home who you invited over while bill I
think he was smoking a blunt there and
the other one's got Neil the grass Ty
and looks like he has like you know
whiskey or something it's like to really
get into it um you got to give credit
where credits do so I will do that I
would also say uh that bill of course is
completely right about the idea is that
he's he's basically saying to this
guy you you're supposed to be someone
who communicates science clearly so why
are you on the side of people who don't
know the difference between boys and
girls because if you if we can't lay out
that basic stuff the things that we all
know to be true then when it gets to
really really complex stuff like
geopolitics let's say then how's anyone
going to know what is true I thought it
was a little bizarre when Neil de grass
heison was like oh well this doesn't
have anything to do with science like
I'm pretty sure gender has something to
do uh with science but degrass Tyson is
really hung up on this nonsense around
uh boys and girls and sports he simply
for some reason wants a bunch of
biological males to dunk over chicks or
Smash Girls in the face when they're
playing Cross or wrestle them to the
ground and put their knee on their
throat or whatever else so Bill's going
off on him we're going to show you one
more clip from this bill's going off on
him on that and then he has a he has
he's very smart he's a lefty and a
liberal so he has he has many ideas on
how to deal with this gender stuff when
it comes to sports match more
interesting for the viewer so if we can
split wrestling into 10 categories and
that becomes the wrestling match but all
men against each other correct so so now
sort of key Point okay okay so all I'm
saying is what is it that makes the man
the man is it the hormones okay is it if
it's the hormones and
you decide to give yourself a different
cocktail of
hormones I'm making this up by the way
I'm not saying it should happen this way
it's a way to start thinking about it
maybe the track meets have hormone
categories and maybe giving yourself the
wrong hormones is deleterious to your
health would you not admit that do you
think we can just safely do things like
this so you feel this way because you're
concerned about you're so deeply
concerned about the health of the people
who are trying to find their place on
the gender Spectrum you care about their
health so much that you don't want them
to go through that it's not something
that keeps me up at night but when the
subject comes up I care about them like
I care about all people so if there is
something you do by the way you think
about all people of course yeah is I
give you that okay you're being think
about all people no I'm being I do yes
yeah old school liberal yeah okay so uh
I want all people to have you know make
this very challenging world that we live
in better so that's why there's honest
debate about this issue and we why don't
we cut it off B honest yeah why don't we
cut it off now because like we're not
going to solve this we set our
pieces nice job Bill and Bill actually
at that moment that's proving that the
good liberal can still exist right
because when he's saying he cares about
both people like the grass Tyson is
trying to dismiss him like you don't
really care about these gender confused
people you're just trying to like what
what he's in essence saying is you're
just plating to those mean people on the
right who don't want it and it's like no
bill actually is saying I do care about
someone who might be young and confused
about their gender or whatever else but
at the same time that doesn't mean I
have to throw out logic and reason so
that we fill them full of hormones and
have them Crush people of the opposite
sex when it comes to sports now if you
want an examp
example of how dangerous this is there
are so many of them and and when we've
talked about this we've usually done it
in the framework of swimming right
because there's obviously there's
wrestling there's basketball there's
every sport you can go across but
swimming seems to be one of the big ones
that that's uh that most people talk
about but I want to show you this video
it's from the weekend this is this is
really disturbing so just get ready to
be disturbed this is a female uh
lacrosse game in Massachusetts and
because of what they call the quote e
equal Play Act there is now a biological
male at least one biological male
playing against the girls the video is
about 20 seconds and uh watch what this
dude does to this young girl this is
high school right this is high school
watch
[Music]
this
classy
sportsmanship all right so you can hear
the screams uh that guy knocked out the
teeth of the female player uh he should
not have been in that game everyone
knows it you afterwards we didn't show
you the part where the the people in the
crowd start screaming and and everyone
knows this is wrong I want to show you
we're going to show you not a close-up
of what happened that's that's the guy
who bashed and and probably disfigured
this girl maybe for her life or at the
very least uh you know caused thousands
and thousands of dollars of of damage
and you know dental work and all the
rest of it so why am I talking about
this in light of everything that's going
on in the world right and the protests
and the war in the Middle East and
everything else why am I talking about
this well there's a broader theme the
people like Neil degrass Tyson who have
confused so many people right we should
have 10 we should have 10 different
categories of high school sports and we
can have chicks with dicks versus girls
with the JJs all of the they confused
everything and then a whole bunch of
young people are just confused about
absolutely everything because again if
you cannot figure out the basic stuff
there are differences between boys and
girls and that 2 plus two does equal
four well then you are ripe you are ripe
to be confused by all of the really
complex stuff as bill referenc there's
really complex stuff that we have to
deal with and of course you're going to
then get that stuff wrong if they have
you confused about everything else hence
why queers for Palestine is very
different than Palestine for quers we're
going to get to all that let me talk to
you guys about the wellness company real
quick uh guys I want to introduce you to
the wellness company and specifically
their medical emergency kit awake
doctors like Dr Peter mullus started the
wellness company to build a parallel
Health Care system and bring about
change in a corrupt and failing
system part of that change is is helping
you take control of your health and
supporting you through whatever the next
thing that gets thrown our way most
people don't trust Healthcare right now
in fact over 40% of Americans say they
would avoid a doctor or a hospital
unless it was a catastrophic situation
that's where the wellness company's
medical emergency kit comes in eight
potentially life-saving medications for
you to keep on hand uh in times of need
natural disasters supply chain shortages
medical emergencies Etc you can rest
easy knowing that you have emergency
antibiotics antivirals and
antiparasitics to help keep you and your
family safe this kit includes a
comprehensive guide book so you never
have to guess how much to take or when
to take it if you're like me and you
want to make sure your family's prepared
for the unexpected go to tww c. rubben
and use code Ruben to save 15% a
checkout that's TW wc. Health rubben Cod
Ruben for 15% off and now back to me
okay so how can we connect the sort of
destruction of all that we know is real
and true and provable and scientific how
can we connect that that collapse to
where we are politically and culturally
right now well there's a lot of ways to
do it and I think a lot a lot of it
should be aimed at our colleges why is
the worst of the worst right now the
places where they are Marching for
genocide from The River To The Sea it is
a call for genocide the places where
they are tearing down pictures of babies
who are kidnapped why is it all Bur ing
forth at our higher uh places of quote
higher education and specifically at our
Elite ones at the elite schools right
like the schools like Harvard and
Stanford well there's uh all sorts of
reasons for that uh so I want to throw
to a clip of Michael nolles who was on
Megan Kelly's show this is on Friday
right he was on Megan Kelly's show on
Friday talking about the woke hypocrisy
of places like Harvard I think he just
nailed it perfectly she was also asked
about the insanity on college campuses
um and what we're seeing there and
suddenly just like those college campus
University presidents she and this White
House have found their commitment to
free speech in America the most
prominent anti-israel pramas protest
we've seen on campus just took place at
Harvard University where you had dozens
of student groups signing this letter
against Israel and in in support of
Hamas a Harvard professor Professor cam
I think her name is at the Harvard
Kennedy School just came out in the
advocate which is some LGBT element op
blog and called me a stochastic
terrorist because in a speech I said
that I don't believe in transgenderism
and I think men and women are different
and one can't become the other and we
should stop entertaining this delusion
uh this professor at Harvard calls me a
stochastic terrorist for saying that
boys and girls are different meanwhile
Harvard is open supporting actual
terrorists who are committing actual
egregious acts of terrorism in the
United States uh and and in Israel with
absolute impunity okay so I want to I
want to connect these things because
Neil degrass Tyson's inability to admit
that men have physical advantage over
women or at least play with this notion
that we should then pump people full of
hormones and we should chop off genitals
and have different categories and all
these things this is directly connected
to people at say The Advocate an LGBT
Elemento p uh magazine as as he put it
I'm pretty sure I was the first one to
come up with that I'm going to need some
credit on that one uh nolles nolles by
the way who is not an anti-gay bigot he
and his wife have had dinner at my house
with David many times over the years
like it's just it's just pure nonsense
there is a fundamental difference
between saying oh we should not Chop
kids genitals off and you know basic
bigotry to say the least uh but the the
broader theme Here is that higher
education academics and their media
cohorts like Anil degrass Tyson they
will lie about anything biological
reality and anyone Michael n's just
laying out the truth as long as it
satisfies their ideology and then what
happens is you get a bunch of kids who
have been brainwashed right and it's a
we're seeing it right now and Tik Tok
has an awful lot to do with this too we
know that they are algorithms because
it's Chinese spyware you want to figure
out what's going on here China has been
pumping our kids full of the wrong ideas
to basically blow apart the the brains
of a generation of our kids right so
they're prot testing in in the name of
things that would gladly impale them or
behead them uh and it infects everything
even forget our IV League schools like
Harvard and Stanford even places like
Oxford Oxford University okay so Ben
Shapiro went to Oxford University last
week I saw him at the Jordan Peterson
event in London the day after and he
debated an Oxford student about Israel
and Hamas and I'm going to show you two
no I think we have three clips of this
uh because it's just it's just so
interesting watching what happens when
your brain has been rotted with ideology
and I have some sympathy actually for
these young people who have been put in
this position it's their it's their
parents and the system before them that
failed them that led them to this place
so you're going to hear some of what
these people have to say and then listen
to Ben honestly clearly explain truth
reality and history here clip one it's
clearly unjust what the IDF has been
doing to the Palestinians because
there's a vast disparity between the
number of Palestinians being killed and
the number of Israelis I mean I would
certainly hope that Israel is killing
more this isn't a conflict this isn't a
conflict this is one-sided ethnic
cleansing again I'm just asking you if
based on the numbers more Germans died
than Brits in World War II did that mean
that British the British were wrong in
World War II because they did many more
Germans died than Brits based on the
numbers that mean that Britain was wrong
in World War II Britain wasn't bombing
civilian
civilians the people of Dres you should
talk to you should talk to the people in
Dresden but you can't because they're
de okay so this is just one example I'm
going to show you a few things now this
girl does simply does not know what
she's talking about but let's let's
unpack both of those things first off
this the secondary idea which is that
Britain didn't bomb uh you know uh that
they didn't bomb places where civilians
were killed like of course it's just
complete nonsense uh the first part this
again this idea of proportionality we
showed you the video was a week and a
half ago or so of Douglas Mari when he
was on a British television show being
asked about proportionality the idea
that oh they killed 1,500 of your men
and women and they burnt people alive
and raped them and all sorts of stuff
and then you should what what would be
the proportional response to that and
the irony of proportion is when you have
a terrorist organization dedicated to
genocide and and sewing chaos and
killing as many people as possible uh
you're not going to believe this but
this is a symptom of the mind of of
Western usually liberals there are bad
people out there they don't play by
rules so one set of people have to play
by no rules use their own people as
human Shields and everything else and
then there's another another set of
people who are decent who who don't want
to kill innocent people but what would
be the proportional response it's it's
just an absolutely profoundly insane
thing they killed, 1500 of our people
and has done Murray said in in that
video it would be hard to find enough
IDF soldiers to rape and kill innocent
Palestinian women and children right so
proportionality is completely ridiculous
you have a duty there is an existential
fight right now there is an organization
dedicated to the destruction of Israel
they have an existential fight and they
have to do what they have to do to
survive the idea of proportionality is
completely insane again was it
proportional when we drop two nukes on
Japan
probably not did it end the war and now
Flash Forward 70 years later is Japan
one of our best allies and is Japan a
pretty sound decent democracy yeah
anyway here's clip two of Ben at Oxford
Palestine Whi which
part really it's a serious question what
what is
it um I'm not going to I mean I saw you
say from The River To The Sea so you can
just say it out loud yeah from River to
yeah there we go okay I appreciate I
appreciate the idea that the Jewish
State should be wiped completely off the
map with a concominant loss of life but
we're worried about climate change and
the humanitarian aspects of climate
change over the course of the next
hundred years sure okay again in some
weird respect I sympathize with these
kids who brains have been so obliterated
that with that girl she doesn't know
what she's doing and she there's a shame
attached to it when she put the mic down
and kind of looked down and then she
talks about River to the Sea because she
doesn't know what she's saying like and
if she really thought about it if they
really thought about it so is what you
want to do is kill 8 million Jews in in
the Middle East uh and you'd probably
have to kill about two million Arab
Israelis who are peacefully living there
as well some of whom are fighting in the
Army right now and the BNS and the and
the Christian Israelis and everything
else they don't know what they are
saying and and then it's not easy you
know as I gave Bill Mah credit uh the
other day Ben probably doesn't want me
to say this but I saw Ben the other day
I saw him a few days after that at the
at the Jordan event at the O2 and you
know emotions were running high and I
was thrilled to see when they brought
Ben on stage when Jordan it was a
surprise that Ben was there and when
when Jordan brought Ben on stage and the
Applause 20,000 people for Ben Ben gets
big Applause you know anywhere he goes
but there was a little something extra
of the Applause because it wasn't just o
Ben Shapiro here it's like he's kind of
like the number one Jew at the moment
right and he's the number one person
fighting this stuff on the front lines
and there was an extra feeling in that
room in London which London's dealing
with all sorts of craziness right now
about that so that was very enlightening
see but I know it's taking a toll on Ben
as it's taking a toll on everybody I
want to show you one more and this is
directly related related to history and
I think that's the point right if again
if we don't know any of the basics of
reality and how are we ever going to
know history or be able to apply it to
our current day
hold on hold on hold on I I listen to
your whole history for like
five minutes here so at least let me
respond to
it your entire claim is that the Arabs
did not reject peace and then in your
own disquisition you admitted that the
Arabs rejected the peel commission plan
which was a separation between the Jews
and the Arabs which gave an
extraordinary amount of land to the
Arabs the Arabs then rejected the peace
partition plan proposed by the United
Nations in 1947 they then proceeded to
reject the Oslo Accords in 93 after that
they rejected the Y River Accords in 98
they rejected AUD barack's very generous
offer in 2000 they rejected OMS very
generous offer in 2008 every single
peace deal that has been proposed by
Israel or anyone else has been rejected
by the Arabs for a very simple reason
which was the very first question I
asked you you do not accept that there
should be a Jewish State anywhere in
this region so as long as that's the
case there's literally nothing to argue
about you cannot simultaneously maintain
the position there should not be a
Jewish State anywhere in the region and
then tell me that I'm wrong when I say
that the Arabs will not accept a
two-state solution you yourself say that
there should not be a two-state solution
and that's kind of where we're at at the
moment the people out there that are
protesting and we're going to get to the
White House protest in just a second
first we're going to show you something
from Obama who has uh who is just I'll
hold that for just a moment um the
people that are out there protesting
it's either that they don't know first
off they have no sense of the reality
right a state known as Palestine never
existed who was the Prime Minister Who
was the president etc etc there was an
area known as Palestine that was part of
the British Empire we've been through
all of this the Palestinian national
soccer team founded by Jews mostly Jews
played on it the Palestine post is now
the Jerusalem Post once the state of
Israel came to be they didn't murder
everybody at the newspaper they were
mostly Jews okay fine the Arab countries
used to boycott Palestine because that's
where the Jews live blah blah blah the
point is that there have been repeated
repeated and this is fact repeated
offers by the not first by the British
right peel commission and the UN
partition plan hey guys we're getting
out of here like our Empire is basically
up you guys all want some land and
you'll figure it out for yourselves and
the Arabs because they were not
Palestinians at the time said no
launched a war lost then Ben went
through the other options one of the
options I forget whether it was the
ahood olare one or or the AUD Barack one
Arafat came back I think it was the the
uh the Barack one because that was with
Bill Clinton Arafat who was the leader
of the PLO at the time he came back and
basically said yes he said to Bill
Clinton it's in his book they're giving
us everything they're giving us 90
something percent even in the spots that
they're not happy they're going to do
land swaps they're giving us the whole
damn thing he said I can't sign this
thing if I sign this thing they'll kill
me so that's the position that we're in
then the Israelis left Gaza altogether
they said we have nobody to make peace
with we'll just have nothing to do with
the place and then they they could have
turned it into the Tel Aviv just a
little more south the most beautiful
beach on the Mediterranean just like Tel
Aviv is and they turned it into a terror
factory that was funded to the tune of
billions with literally your tax dollars
and and a whole bunch more so think
about it if these kids who are at the
most elite academic institutions at the
West Harvard well we're told Elite they
were Elite I guess at one point now
they're just brainwashing clone
factories but Harvard Cambridge Oxford
Yale etc etc these places have become a
absolute Cesspool of left-wing
radicalism and then they have pushed
students into voting for all of the
wrong people and in essence destroying
all of our ins institions so now that
we're talking about destroying
institutions and voting for the wrong
people here's a guy that I voted for
twice and I freaking regret it may it be
on my Tombstone that could be on my
Tombstone not you know beloved husband
good father he regretted voting for
Obama twice here is University of
Chicago uh law student uh two-time
President Barack Obama over the weekend
and who's to blame for what's happening
in the Middle East well it's you
actually if there's any chance of us
being able to act constructively to do
something it will require an admission
of
complexity and maintaining what on the
surface may seem contradictory
ideas that that what Hamas did was
horrific and there's no justification
for
it and what is also true is
that the the
occupation and what's happening to
Palestinians
is is
unbearable and you then have to
admit nobody's hands are
clean
that all of us are complicit to some
degree uh no you fraud I'm not complicit
Conor you complicit in what's happening
over there Phoenix complicit Brock you
complicit in this thing oh
BR all right Brock's a little complicit
uh no Barack Obama is complicit he's
complicit because even right there he is
lying about the history there is no
occupation and there was no occupation
right there simply was not they can keep
saying it so what he's in essence saying
is what Hamas did was bad and he doesn't
say but it's interesting and he's really
clever with words normally they would
say but what Hamas did was was horrific
but and then they give the excuse but he
doesn't use the word but he says what
Hamas did was horrific and we must look
at the occupation there is not one Jew
living in Gaza the most extreme
right-wing Israeli four months ago did
not want to go back into Gaza did not
want to get one Jew there by the way
it's not working out that well for other
minorities there as well there is and
was no occupation Egypt also has a
border for for some reason Barack Obama
is not too worried about what Egypt's
doing so when he says he says in essence
he's saying we all have to look at
ourselves we and this it's just this
lofty
self-righteous you wanted to do
something Obama you could have told the
truth when you were president for eight
years you could have said hey instead of
funding Hamas and the Palestinian
Authority who were paying people to kill
Jews and lying about the two-state
solution and everything else you could
have said hey Hamas the Israelis want
nothing to do with you even right now
think about how insane it is everyone's
saying that the the Israelis are
invading Gaza right now how are they
invading Gaza if they were occupying it
before ah because there was no
occupation so yes they're invading it
now with 1500 dead people trying to find
200 uh 200 hostages but Obama you're
partly to blame you are complicit and my
suspicion is any of the real pressure
that's coming from uh from Democrats on
Biden who's been like sort of good on
this even though you don't know if it's
Biden or not it's coming from the
radical Obama camp and they are figuring
out a way uh to get rid of Biden we'll
talk more about that uh later in the
week but anyway you are complicit Barack
Obama because you could have done
something all those years instead of
going after Israel which you were doing
constantly you could have basically said
to Hamas hey just just give up the death
chance I know it would be tough to you
know you have a charter but could you
just let it go and not want to kill all
the Jews and then build your state and
everyone would have helped you do it
they would have had they would have had
the the Tel Aviv or the Paris or the
London or whatever City the Bora Bora of
Gaza they could have done it and people
would have loved to have been there
because it also would have been kind of
spitting in the Israelis eyes right and
they would have kind of dug that but the
problem is when we have people like
Barack Obama who lie about their
involvement they lie about the history
and all of those things you end up also
getting a set of people in government
who are not very good people one of
those not very good people is a Woman by
the name of Nea Ali and it turns out
that she is working at the Department of
Homeland Security and she is a radical
Palestinian activist and you might be
concerned in light of what's happening
with the border and people calling to
destroy Israel and Destroy America take
over the west and the chance for the
Muslim armies in London to take over
that country you might not want someone
like this working in the Department of
Homeland Security so one politician
who's actually pretty decent is
Republican Josh Holly and there was a
hearing on uh this lady well there was a
hearing on the border largely and uh he
got into it with Alexander Alejandro
sorry Alejandro mayoras about uh this
radical Palestinian employee of the
Department of Homeland Security let let
me ask you about people who say other
things what about people who say things
like on October the 7th F Israel I'm
cleaning up the language here F Israel
the government and its military
are you ready for your
downfall people who say things like f
Israel and any Jew who supports Israel
may your conscience haunt your dreams
and tell your last breath Palestine will
be free one day F apartheid Israel and
is any Israeli what this is pretty
extreme rhetoric don't you think Senator
um I do and I think there is a
distinction between espousing or
endorsing terrorist ideology and and uh
Speech uh that is uh odious that does
not rise to that um level fair enough
this person works for you this is nja
Ali an employee of the Department of
Homeland Security who posted these
comments on October the 7th that's not
all she posted this is a paraglider a
Hamas
paraglider depicted here with a machine
gun flying into Israel she posted it
under her online
Alias with the celebratory free
Palestine Mr secretary what what's going
on here is this is this typical of of
people who work at DHS this is an asylum
and immigration officer who is posting
these frankly pro- genocidal
slogans and images on the day that
Israelis are being slaughtered in their
beds what have you done about this four
things I'd like to say to you number one
your question to suggest that that is
emblematic of the men and women of the
Department of Homeland Security is
Despicable I'm sorry what have you this
person works for the Department of
Homeland Security have you fired her
that was one of four answers have you
fired her I'm not even getting into the
other three how dare you ask me how dare
you besmer the good name of the people
of Department of Homeland Security just
because some lady who put up a poster of
a guy paragliding with a gun into Israel
after they it's just extraordinary the
other extraordinary thing of course is
his eyebrows mayorcas his eyebrows I
want to do a whole can we do a
documentary about may orcus his eyebrows
we're going to go out on the road I want
to talk to eyebrow experts all over the
world find out what's going on there
okay it it turns out that this woman has
been
promoted no just kidding uh she is she
is temporarily suspended so at least
they did something there but even I
don't have to give you the other three
answers that he gave this this righteous
IND how dare you say something bad about
these people we are in a real pickle of
a bind in a thingy that's sinking
because guys like mayorcas are in charge
of the border and it's a real problem
but let's move on because there are also
people like representative pamila gapul
and this woman is just terrible
fortunately you can see it on her face
that she knows how terrible she is uh
here she is I think this is from CNN
calling for a ceasefire now I just want
to preface this by saying she's not nor
has once called for just Americans to be
released you might say the thing to do
is just oh it's MSNBC sorry this is
MSNBC with Jen saki uh propagandist who
used to work at the White House who now
works in mainstream corporate media you
might just say if you were an
American um how about no preconditions
just release the Americans to me that
seems like the American position that
you might take but Premier gal is
actually a member of the Hamas caucus
and she wants to do it a little bit
differently when I call for ceasefire
that means a stoppage immediately of
Israel's bombing and attacks uh air
strikes as well as the ground attacks um
in order to make sure that we can get
the hostages back and that we can get
humanitarian Aid into Gaza and that we
have a plan for how to move forward I
don't think the question is about
whether we should take allow Israel to
take out Hamas and whether all the
international allies would be in favor
of taking out Hamas that is absolutely
true the question is how to do that and
there is increasing toll both with
civilians in in Gaza uh you know
violence in the West Bank I do think
that we need to recognize that this
crisis is not going to end and Hamas is
not going to be taken out unless there
is a political situation that allows
both Israelis and Palestinians to
coexist with
self-determination um next to each other
other and and that is something that
can't happen while Israel is continuing
to bomb and kill innocent civilians in
Gaza try not to curse I'm trying not to
curse I also don't want to break a
Sharpie and ruin my shirt there's so
much evil double speak there again just
the basic basic part is that the
American position if we had functional
decent people right now would be you
release the Americans let's put the
Israelis aside for a moment you release
the Americans do we have any ability to
put diplomatic pressure on anyone forget
Hamas how about their leaders in Qatar
can we not put pressure on anybody why
is she not demanding right now first
she's like oh no no you need the you
need the ceasefire first so we can get
the uh hostages back it's simply untrue
if Hamas right now made a call somebody
has a call somebody has a phone over
there they still have electricity uh and
just said hey we're releasing we're
releasing all the hostages right now or
even we're just releasing the Americans
you know damn well that the United
States would force Israel to stop
whether whether they wanted to or not
they would there would be a pause but
they don't really want that what they're
upset by and and every single person do
not be mistaken about this every single
person who is demanding a ceasefire
right now the only reason they are
demanding a ceasefire is because Israel
in essence is winning right now they've
cut off Northern Gaza north to south
they have Gaza City in the middle that's
where they believe that the the uh
hostages are and they are slowly taking
them out and they are doing everything
they can not to uh make not to kill
innocent people right if they wanted to
they could end this in a day they could
carpet bomb the whole damn place and
kill tons and tons of people they
wouldn't have to make calls please leave
the building uh no other country would
do this please leave the building we're
about to momb because there's a
terrorist beneath you and we know that
and telling everyone to go south there's
plenty video now of a road that's opened
up so people are walking South but jopal
and the rest of the Hamas caucus like
Rashida Talib and ilhan Omar and AOC and
a huge portion of the Democrats
they want Israel to lose do you think if
Israel was losing right now if there
were just that and by the way anything
can switch in a moment there are still
hundreds of rockets being shot to Israel
there could be any sort of uh incursion
through the water or through the fence
or anything else but do you think right
now if it was mostly Israelis dying that
any of the do you think the people
protesting at the White House or jaipal
or AOC do you think they'd be calling
for a ceasefire no they'd be saying you
you they would be saying uh you people
are getting exactly what you deserve
that's exactly what they were saying so
when they say ceasefire a ceasefire is
only a chance for Hamas to reload if she
wants coexistence I think that was the
word she said which dare her even that
that it even comes out of her mouth
there is one place in the Middle East
that has coexistence that has equal
rights between Arab and Jew and it's
called Israel it's the place you hate
the most but if you want to see the rot
of the Democrat Party uh it's not just
the AOC those easy Hamas caucus ones to
go after this rot is now it's it's sort
of prolif erating throughout the entire
party that there really are no moderates
anymore so here's Democrat Senator Dick
Durban from Illinois and he's thought of
as more of a moderate but what is he he
also wants a ceasefire we can't have
Israel actually winning the war and
ending these people is a ceasefire
needed
now I think it is at least under in the
context of both sides agreeing for
example the release of those who have
been kidnapped should be part of this
immediate release
uh that should be the beginning of it uh
an effort should be made to engage in
conversation between the Israelis and
the Palestinians let's face it this has
gone on for decades uh whatever the
rationale from the beginning it has now
reached an intolerable level uh we need
to have a resolution in the Middle East
that gives some promise for the future
have you told the president the White
House you think it's time for a
ceasefire because that is a word that
the president is intentionally not using
well believe me what I said earlier
about ceasefires under circumstances for
example the release of those who have
been kidnapped as part of it indication
that this is a good faith effort on the
part of the other
side meaningless dribble it's just
meaningless dribble he is a United
States Senator he could say hey we have
I believe 12 Americans hostage right now
Hamas release
them release them release them or we're
going to let Israel do whatever it wants
or we are going to get involved or
anything else but no Israel's starting
to win they're doing what they got to do
to survive which is exactly what this is
all about this is not whether the
Palestinians can survive the
Palestinians can survive if they just
try to stop killing all the Jews this is
about whether Israel can survive and
when Israel is starting to get the upper
hand we better have a ceasefire and
unfortunately as I said this is
proliferating throughout the Democrat
Party well even the elderly man
pretending to be President Joe Biden
who's sort of given the right statements
so far it sounds like he's waffling a
little bit uh we have a tweet from BPR
uh Biden appears to bow to leftists on
Israel ceasefire this is over the
weekend I think we need a pause
President Joe Biden has called for a
humanitarian pause in the Israel Hamas
War sparking Anger from Israel's many
staunch Defenders we we'll see what
happens with that um but the idea that
there would be a pause while they they
are still shooting Rockets literally
this second there are still being
Rockets shot in imagine what America
would do if 6,000 Rockets were shot in
from Canada right we bomb Mexico so they
have no um they have no Duty or it's not
it's not even a reason they have no
reason for a ceasefire and they have no
Duty they have a moral obligation to
their citizens who are living to honor
their citizens who are killed and to do
something about those hostages but again
if you have a whole bunch a generation
and I would say many generations at this
point of people who have grown up
through universities and an academic
atmosphere where they don't know that
good is good and bad is bad they don't
know anything about history as Ben tried
to lay out to that girl or as as dick
deran says well we have to give them
hope there has to be some sort of peace
process japal we need some sort of
coexistence yes one side is saying we're
going to kill all of you right and the
other side saying we would prefer not to
all be killed some of you unfortunately
are going to have to die so we make sure
that that doesn't happen to
us like it's just obvious so anyway what
happened over the weekend well there was
an Insurrection at the White House here
is the pramas riers uh climbing the
fence of the White House and trying to
get in I thought this was an
Insurrection and we're going to have to
do something about it but
[Applause]
yeah
I'm just going to keep pointing it out
as long as this nonsense goes on again
if you don't care about Israel and you
don't care about the Jews okay I think
there's reasons that you should uh but
you should care about yourself and if
you think these people will be done when
they are done with Israel just wait just
wait just ask the people of London and
the people of Paris Brussels and
Amsterdam if they wish they had done
something a little bit more when these
people were coming into their countries
and protesting the way they are do you
think these people care about the First
Amendment the Second Amendment do you
think they care about your free speech
and your liberal values and everything
else they're chanting God is great in
front of the White House do you think
this is really just about the Jews uh no
it's actually about destroying our
history they want to disconnect the
Jewish people from the ancient land of
Israel just like they want to disconnect
America and our founding from this land
here which which is a lot uh a lot
younger right our history is a lot
shorter than that ancient Israel Place
uh and that's why they are also going
after our monuments will anyone be
arrested for this I I'd like to bet
someone 25 cents that says
[Applause]
[Music]
no
[Applause]
what they said they were bringing freed
they were
bringing yeah so they're desecrating our
mins we've been through this all before
and just like it was all Bs it was all
trumped up evil when it was BLM that's
exactly what it is right now that was
Ben Franklin being covered up right
there free pal look we have video of all
of these people masks or not all of
these people would be easily
identifiable and easily arrestable we
will not do anything you guys know that
that's a farone conclusion this
Administration ain't going to do jack
about it we know that they kind of
like it in in a bizarre way but Obama is
not upset by any of this he's looking at
Biden figuring out like his Obama you
could tell he's like he's licking his
lips right now
like we almost done with Biden how we
going to get in someone more radical
Gavin
Newsome let's see what we can figure out
here but the the radicalism of these
people is is only out
uh I would say outpaced by the general
stupidity and now I'm going to show you
just some general stupidity there is a
singer I guess by the name of melmore
mmore I I don't know about this mmore I
don't know do we know a does anyone here
know I feel like you know a song by
mmore do you know a song
by there apparently melmore saying about
being in a thrift shop in the third
grade I I don't know about this mmore
anyway this mmore person showed up to
the uh the free pales rally you know I
don't know about mamore I like Frank
Sinatra I like Frankie Valley I like who
else do I like I like that Tina Turner
um I would have you know the Tina Turner
show was playing when I was in London
but I thought can I go to a theater and
see a Tina Turner play without getting
beheaded which that's that's an odd
thought that I never thought I was gonna
have anyway here's
melmore who's a great voice for Hamas at
the uh Jihad rally in DC there are
thousands of people here that are more
qualified to speak on the issue of a
free Palestine than myself but I will
say
this they told me to be
quiet they told me to do my research to
go back that it's too complex to say
something right to be silent In This
Moment In the last 3 weeks I've gone
back and I've done some research and I'm
teachable I don't know enough but I know
enough
this is a
genocide I don't know what I'm talking
about I know nothing about the history
there are thousands of people standing
right in front of me who'd be better
qualified to talk about any of this but
kill all the Jews
mother so what happened guys how did it
come to this from the riots the rot of
our culture the destruction of our
history and the the complete
patheticness of our political leaders
well it's actually fairly obvious if
you've been paying attention our nation
was subverted a long time ago by a lot
of Bad actors like that George Soros guy
and a lot of the people who decided we
will just do the Long March through the
institutions they committed
demoralization of our nation through the
Marx ification of our education system I
wish I had said that with a little more
of a rhyme like I was on
MSNBC but they've done it and it was
intentional now I want to show you a
video we've shown some clips of this guy
over the years uh this is a guy by the
name of Yuri bezmenov he is a former
Soviet KGB officer he was a subversion
expert and in this video and this is
from about 40 years ago he explains how
the marxists and the Communists will
take over how they will use all of the
freedoms of the West to take out the
west and you tell me if this kind of
sounds on the money and if you're seeing
it happen right now ideological
subversion that is a phrase that uh I'm
afraid some Americans don't fully
understand when uh the Soviets use the
phrase ideological subversion what do
they mean by ideological subversion is
is the slow process which we call either
ideological subversion or active
measures AC in the language of of the
KGB or psychological warfare Fair what
it basically means is to change the
perception of reality of every
American to such an extent that despite
of the abundance of
information no one is able to come to
sensible conclusions in the interest of
Defending themselves their families
their community and their
country it's a great
brainwashing uh process which goes very
slow and it's divided in in four basic
stages
uh the first one being demoralization it
takes from 15 to 20 years to demoralize
a nation why that many years because
this is the minimum number of years
which requires to educate one generation
of
students in the country of of of your
enemy exposed to the ideology of the
enemy in other words Marxism leninism
ideology is being pumped into the soft
heads of of of at least three
generations of American student students
without being challenged or
counterbalanced by the basic values of
americanism American Patriot we we'll
keep showing you more of that I wanted
to be somewhat brief in that he gets
into all four of the versions but
demoralization so that all of the bad
ideas as he said three generations of
people will have been fed all of the
wrong ideas the ideas that are counter
to America and counter to freedom and
capitalism and our founding documents
and all that and you won't even know you
won't even know as Douglas Murray says
The Barbarians will be at the gate and
we will be debating what gender pronouns
to call them so these people who are
protesting at the White House and
screaming about genocide they they don't
know actually that there is no genocide
there's an attempted genocide of the
Jews but there is no genocide of the
Palestinians the Palestinian population
has 5x in 50 years that's not how
genocides work Jews are generally
thought of as pretty good with math a
lot of Jewish accountants
but they will not know what they are
protesting you will have demoralized
people perhaps by having girls having
their teeth knocked out at lacrosse
matches by boys and then thinking that
you have to plot it all the way around
you got it you got what's going on here
but the other part of course that they
will demoralize us is is they will make
you as say a white person think that you
are inherently guilty of something and
then they will push race into every one
of our subjects in all of our schools
even things that have nothing to do with
race like math and science check out
this video of Virginia school district
which has created a new AP class called
African-American studies and you're not
going to believe this one it's actually
going to replace the math and science
course but well go ahead all right let's
get right to it here at South County
High School in Lorden these students are
hard at work making masterpieces
recreating sculptures like the ones you
would see in ancient western Africa step
shows you have a lot of things that have
cultural sensibilities talking about
things like black joy and historically
black colleges and universities it's all
part of the new AP African-American
studies pilot class my goal is to get
them holistic history as much
information as possible and then
hopefully they'll take that information
to make the world a better place I felt
like there was like a gap in my
knowledge about African history so I
thought this class would be a great way
to like deepen my knowledge the class
launched after months of drama
Nationwide black
Joy I didn't know there was like joy
that was different between the races I I
thought Joy was like a kind of human
thing happiness love I thought these
sort of you know they subverted the
traditional lines we might think of I
think of black Joy I wish we had a video
of George Jefferson dancing like that's
to me black joy and it's not that far
from White Joy right like it's just not
but okay you will teach kids AP class
classes that they will get college
credit for in high school they will they
will make sculptures so they can learn
about black Joy I somehow think black
Joy might come at the expense of white
Freedom we shall see but now I just want
to show you one more from high school
this this is really wild this was going
uh viral over the weekend as well this
is from a National High School debate
that took place on zoom and and you are
you might fall out of your chairs on
this one if you just watch how they have
broken National High School debates
these are supposed to be the brightest
kids debating the most important things
in a decent honorable respectful way and
just watch the way this thing devolves
they have a white debat on their team
which inherently means they have more
whiteness than us we obviously know that
JJ is not white it's pretty obvious go
down onto our pick we give you three
Wars why we subsume all of their
protests and affirm their protest in a
pick what it means is you are furthering
their cause just minus the whiteness as
Rebecca is a vehicle for this Movement
we say whiteness is really bad for
representation and queer people and it's
a bad form of furthering this protest
whiteness is bad for queer people I'm
GNA I you know what someone find me a
gay white guy and I'm going to find out
what's what on that one um the hysteria
the over emotion all of the stuff right
and that poor girl Rebecca I'm with you
Rebecca can we send Rebecca something
let's find if anyone can get us in touch
with Rebecca like find out what Rebecca
likes I I'll get Rebecca a little
something for having to listen to that
harping lunatic but again I have some
sympathy for these young people because
the entire system did it to them right
so now as we get towards the ending of
the show you know what I'm going to do
I'm going to try to give you an
alternative I'm going to try to give you
a forward positive Vision I'm going to
try to give you something that's robust
and truthful and encouraging about the
west and its founding I think I can do
it and believe it or not I'm going to
get it from a liberal let's go back to
Bill Maher who I think is he's I don't
know that he'll ever vote the right way
but he's having his red pill moment let
him have it here he is and finally new
rule for all the progressives and
academics who refer to Israel as an
outpost of Western Civilization like
it's a bad thing please note Western
Civilization is what gave the world
pretty much every goddamn liberal
precept that Liberals are supposed to
adore individual liberty scientific
inquiry rule of law religious freedom
women's rights human rights democracy
trial by jury freedom of speech please
somebody stop us before we Enlighten
again so that's what we're up against
and Bill's in that that little sliver of
liberals let's say who are still trying
to do it but if you care about any of
those things and look I get it the the
let's say most radical islamist and
Marxist portion of those protesters
maybe they don't care about those things
they either want us to to live in some
caliphate or they want us you know the
marxists want us to all live under their
thumb or something but if you watching
this right now if you have a cousin
that's confused about this stuff or a
child who's confused about this or a
parent or whatever that's not really
like a psychotic ideologue like lunatic
you have a little window right now to to
Deb brainwash these people you got to
deprogram these people and you better do
it quick or it will keep getting worse
everything will keep getting worse so we
have to strength the people who are
fighting it and and we have to make sure
that the people who are going down those
roads know what the truth is but but I
will tell you this although as I say I'm
a world weary Optimist I mean the chips
are stacked against us there's just
simply no doubt right Generations as
Yuri bov talked about generations of
people have already been brainwashed you
have people trampling and and uh you
know def desecrating the the statues of
Thomas Jefferson Thomas Jefferson who
lived lived a very complex life at a
difficult time to ultimately free the
slaves and to write the founding
documents that freed more people
minority or otherwise than have ever
been freed in the history of the world
in this great United States and they
think he's the bad guy now so you better
stand up while you can because uh
otherwise frog pot it's getting warmer
and it does not end well for the Frog uh
guys if you have not subscribed please
do at rumble.com Ruben report I should
note that we are launching a show today
how did I not mention that at the top of
the show that's right uh Monday through
Thursday going forward on Rumble it'll
be on Rumble and on locals we are
launching uh people of the internet this
is a show I've wanted to do for a long
time where we get you guys involved
we're going to take calls from you guys
we're going to do video and audio calls
from you guys because I've often thought
that as many times as I sit down with
great enlight enlightened thinkers and
all these cool people and CBS and blah
blah blah uh that you guys actually have
as much if not more insight than them so
I have wanted to do a show like this for
a long time Rumble has just launched a
new studio uh that's going to be our
internal software we're running on this
thing so we're going to be the first
show that does this using the rumble
software I'm psyched about that my
friend Isabelle Brown who's been on the
show before that many of you guys know
uh she's going to be joining me as
co-host and the other thing that I've
tasked her with so there's going to be
two components to the show it's going to
be calls from you guys and I've said to
Isabelle I want you to pick like three
Clips every morning I don't want to see
them in a Advance not things that we did
on the Regular Show like the meat of the
day on the on the main Ruben report but
just like other things about people of
the internet like what else is going on
in the culture I will see them real time
we will react we'll take your calls I'm
super psyched so if you want to join us
for that it'll be on our locals Channel
it'll be at rumble.com rubben report
we're doing that in conjunction with
tenet which is a new online Network that
they help facilitate uh some of this
which I'm psyched to be part of I'll
tell you all more about that later today
but that'll be 1 p.m. every Monday
through Thursday so if you're subscribed
on Rumble it's not going to be on our
YouTube channel if you're subscribed on
Rumble you will get it right there we
leave you with a cold close of the
elderly man pretending to be president
uh kind of blaming somebody else for
something that he himself is doing
goodbye the world has changed because
what Trump has done and the American
people including Independents and some
Republicans know how bad he is know how
much he's misrepresented know how he's
getting close to getting this in a war I
said as the walls close in on this man
I'm worried he's going to get us to war
in Iran unfortunately I may have been
right the fact of the matter is there's
a lot of stake in this
[Music]
election